sue is in California
hi Sue how are you hi thank you day
thanks for taking my call sure here's my
question
it's about a trust and I just want to
know if I'm kind of out of line asking
something to be modified my husband has
a trust set up for me for when he passes
and just to give you a little background
he has a network of six million dollars
and I have about a half a million and he
has a trust set up to have provided for
me an income of 80,000 a year and when I
passed and all monies go back into the
trust our process to a to a donation
that he has set up
I've asked if he could gift me I don't
know the right words for it but 10% of
his net worth at the time of passing so
I would have funds to buy a larger home
if I needed it currently the home that
we have I would get that it's about 900
square feet it's a 3-bedroom 1-bath it's
a small cottage like home and if the
elderly were murdered we've been married
20 years when I was married once before
he was never married okay no you're not
out of line as a matter of fact I would
go further than you're going I got to
tell you if I suggested to Sharon Ramsey
that I was going to control her life
from the grave that would not go over
well
yeah I'd have a mad hillbilly woman on
my hands she would say I got a different
idea for you Bubba you know it says
about how it sounded our house this is
very controlling and so it's it says if
he wants his little money that he's got
his little six million dollars to go
where he wants it to go even from the
grave and he doesn't trust his wife of
20 years his primary job is to not to
dance on the money it's to take care of
his wife and you're like a full-grown
woman you should be able to make like
decisions and stuff yes and I've tried
four times to bring this conversation up
and we talked at length about it's not a
quick conversation but it's something he
just is very strong and adamant about
he's very controlling yeah yeah he likes
to get his way a lot I know this guy cuz
I'm him I'm pretty much the same guy
except I've just learned it relationally
what he's proposing here is a bad play
because it makes you feel demeaned it's
as if you're a child this is if you're a
child or an adult with special needs or
something it's just that's how it sounds
on the outside looking in so I
completely say I'm throwing a flag he's
out of bounds you asked me and you're
gonna get my opinion I'm an expert on my
opinion so I may just be causing another
fight here but I think if you guys can't
get through this you probably ought to
bring in an outside counselor like a
marriage counselor to explain to him how
demeaning and controlling this is okay
do you think let me stop it do you think
I'm wrong sure
no yeah and I called to find out if I
was wrong and I I'm agreeing with you I
don't think it's unreasonable because
ask for 10% and you're saying it should
probably be more than 10 like on a
hundred like we are married yeah it's
our stuff twenty freaking years it's our
stuff you share a bed you share a meal
you share travel you share a life you
share tragedy you share money yeah
you're not his roommate at that this is
old school right here I'm a I'm a
dinosaur but that's how I see it
and and I'm not trying to cause trouble
with y'all but I really think that I do
want to solidify that you're not crazy
and he is controlling he doesn't mean to
be he thinks he's being caring all of us
that are controlled people I'm a control
person
we all think we're caring when we're
doing it but then you have to stop and
go no that's really not caring that's
just you being a butt and I I that's
that's happened to me I can so I can
read his mail a little bit because I got
that same DNA I'm I'm the guy tells
people what to do when they freaking do
it you know I mean that's me so I
understand I'm not picking on him too
bad but I am calling him out as a
brother of you know I'm in the
fraternity of control freaks me and him
are in the same frat so I can call him
out as a frat brother and go dude
you're messing up here so that's how
that that's the spirit I'm coming at
this with but I'm also wanting to inject
a little encouragement into you so that
you go ahead and push this a little bit
because I think it's fair for you to
push this more than a little bit just
just my thoughts